all right let's talk about the clowns
over at cnn so brian stelter as you guys
know he hosts
reliable sources i mean this is i say it
all the time it's the most
ironically named television show
ever i mean it is it should be called
unreliable sources then you got a solid
show i'll never talk about it again like
a little honesty in the in the title
would be nice
well anyway brian stelter had uh author
michael wolfon now michael wolf has
written a couple books
about donald trump that are sort of that
i think at times have been debunked i i
don't think this guy is anyone sort of
spectacular but he sort of deserves
cnn and cnn deserves him and anyway
he went on stelter's show yesterday
and absolutely wrecked him on live
tv so well get popcorn and
take a look i think the media has done a
terrible job on this
i think you yourself um you know why
you're a nice guy you know you're full
of sanctimony
um you know you become part of one of
the parts of the problem of the media
you know you come on here and you and
you have a um
you know a monopoly on truth you know
you know exactly how things
are supposed to be done um you know you
are why one of the reasons people can't
stay in the media
i'm sorry
they're cracking me up it's your fault
it's how
so what should i do differently michael
i yeah you know don't talk so much
listen more
you know people have genuine problems
with it with
with the media the media doesn't get the
story right
the media exists in its own bubble
um that's true i agree
um you know you gotta stop i mean that
last segment that
that that i just had to listen to of all
the people saying
the same old stuff also you're
incredibly repetitive
it's week after week i mean you're the
flip side of
of of donald trump um you know
fake news and you say virtuous news
you know i they're they're not they just
figure out what is real i mean
yeah well well figuring out yeah
figuring out what is real is not so
is not so uh it's not so easy and and
you know most people don't want to talk
turn to brian stelter to tell us what's
real
i'm sorry most people don't want to turn
to brian stelter to tell us what's real
i'm sorry okay so first off again this
michael wolf guy i don't want to make it
about him
he's written a couple over-the-top books
about donald trump that some of the i
think the book that came out during the
administration was heavily debunked so
it's not really about him what's nice
about this though
is that every now and again every now
and again
something true can actually come through
the airwaves
in essence of course what wolf is saying
there is true you stelter are part of
the problem
and what does stelter do he's laughing
he's laughing and then his line is
you're cracking me up
you're cracking me up imagine if i was
on air with someone
and they just started full-on assaulting
my
very integrity and everything that i do
you think i'd be ready
to fight back you think anyone with any
wherewithal with any belief in what they
were doing
would actually push back no i am not
that i am not a fraud i am not a liar
etc etc but stelter's really got
nothing he's just got nothing and then
the way he talks about them being
repetitive
and everything else so again i know that
their ratings are in the tank and it's
one of those things you know how often
do we have to expose them versus by
talking about them are we giving more
air to them
and that whole thing but it is nice to
know that there was
some blue-pilled person that watches the
brian stelter
reliable sources program that was
watching it yesterday morning
that heard something somewhat true on
cnn because you ain't gonna hear
anything else true on cnn
now that all being said we have a
cracked
team of researchers here and video
editors
here at the reuben report professional
people doing professional things all day
long
and we put together a little something
special
related to that video here you go i
think you yourself
um you know why you're a nice guy you
know you're full of sanctimony
um you know you become part of one of
the parts of the problem
of the media you are why one of the
reasons people can't stay in the media
i'm sorry
you're cracking me up you know don't
talk so much listen more
you know most people don't want to talk
turn to brian stelter
to tell us what's real i'm sorry
look you might say dave you're above
that and
the aunt the truth is no i'm not above
that
he's humpty dumpty he's half humpty
dumpty half potato
pretending to be a newsman on cnn and he
deserves
the humor that we bring to it